hey 42 here married women were
originally banned from watching the
Olympic Games in ancient Greece if they
did they were promptly thrown off a
cliff welcome to RIF for decades the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration have been tracking a
single mysterious whale that speaks its
own language it sings at a frequency
that no of a whale transmits at it has
been called the world's loneliest whale
in South Korea two barbers poles
spinning next to each other in opposite
directions are used to signify a brothel
the anti-piracy group green who are
responsible for putting the anti-piracy
out on all your DVDs was sued for
stealing the theme song during World War
two a US soldier named Dirk jave vlog
was ambushed by five Japanese tanks he
single-handedly destroyed all five and
was eventually awarded the Medal of
Honor in the dark ages up to the 1800s
animals were sentenced for human crimes
Doug's pigs cows rats and even flies
were prosecuted in court on charges
ranging from murder to obscenity at
Birth babies don't have kneecaps
kneecaps do not completely develop until
after six months after a male penguin
falls in love he will search the entire
beach to find the perfect pebble to give
to her the average American eats an
amount of fat equivalent to one whole
stick of butter each day for every human
killed by a shark humans kill 2 million
sharks and finally if a person yelled
for eight years seven months and six
days he or she will produce enough
energy to heat up just one cup of
coffee thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42